Americans love their independence.
A nation of pioneers who live away from the watchful eye of the government.
(except for all government).
For example, unlike other countries, Americans do not have a national ID card ...
... and even the idea of ​​making one is every election a popular topic.
The result is always the same: "We don't need no ID card."
But strangely enough, US citizens have this:
a card with a unique number that many places will ask for as proof of who you are.
This is the "Social Security" card and number ...
... and it has become, as it were, an ID / unique password to identify citizens ...
... but that was never what it was intended for.
For Americans it is extremely important to keep this number secret,
because it is the key for the government and for banks to identify you as you ...
... and losing control of it is the worst form of identity theft that can happen.
So how did Americans end up with a national ID number ...
... that there is not one and a card is not suitable for identification?
It all started in the great Depression of long, long ago ...
... when the government made the social security program; ...
... a kind of compulsory pension:
Citizens are required to pay during the period in which they work ...
... and take money from them when they retire.
The idea is that even when you have not saved from the past ...
for the later years of future-you, the ultimately old, current you ...
... still has something to live on.
To think that social security is a benefit that the government gives you ...
... or that it is a bank account that is yours ...
... is ... controversial, but anyway, this song was made ...
... to keep track of what you put in and what you get out of it.
Well, because it's just a government program, related to the period that you work, ...
... you only had to request a card when you actually started working.
But over time that has changed and the younger you are, ...
... the more likely it is that you will have one from the moment you were born, ...
... despite the uselessness of babies as child laborers.
So why?
It comes back to Americans who do not have a national identity card with a national number, ...
... which makes it more difficult for institutions to keep an eye on people's lives.
With a hundred million citizens,
names and birthdays that are not unique,
people move, people get married, people change their names ..
And if you try to keep track of everyone, ...
... as the tax authorities of the United States would like to do ...
... that can be a big problem, especially in the days before the computer.
"Hey, wait a minute. Look at * this * number that just lies here,"
said the tax authorities.
"It is not intended to be used as an ID number,"
Said the social security department.
"" There are security reasons why you don't-- "
"Yoink!"
For example, the tax authorities have made useful use of the work done by the social security department; ...
... link all working adults to a number, ...
... which made tax tracking easier ...
... and she strongly encouraged parents to take a number ...
... for their children, by applying a tax reduction.
Strangely enough, counting children for tax credits used trust, ...
The US tax authorities said to the people:
1. We will give you a discount on your tax for every child you have. And:
2. Write down how many children you have ...
please be honest; we have no way of checking it.
What people just ask, no, beg to lie.
Whatever they did, give birth to millions of ghost children on paper.
But after every child was forced to have a number linked to a birth certificate ...
... before the parents could get their tax credit, ...
all these ghosts have been swept away.
This changed the number to a unique number ...
... that all citizens had it right from the start,
And that made it easy for a lot of other places, ...
... such as banks and schools and companies and landlords ...
... to also use the number as an easy way ...
... to keep an eye on people, without creating their own system, ...
... and to make it possible to share information about people between two institutes.
This is extremely useful for institutions, so ...
... the desire of Americans not to have a national identity card led ...
... somewhat inevitable, ...
... to use the most similar thing available as a replacement ...
... which was even worse, because the social security number ...
... was never designed to be used that way in the distant past.
You can see that because there is no security in it.
There is a handy trick that most ID numbers use ...
... where they can check themselves if they are invalid.
The simplest way is to make the sum of the rest by the last few digits.
A lot of different ID cards and barcodes do this, because it makes it impossible ...
... entering incorrect numbers in a computer ...
... and makes it harder for fraudsters to guess correct numbers.
This is how when you try to buy something online by ...
... guess a credit card number, the website knows it is incorrect ...
... before you click on 'buy'.
But because the social security number is his life ...
... started a long time ago, it's just a number ...
... without a built-in, self-checking protection
In fact, if you were born before 2011, it's not that hard to guess the number:
The first three numbers are the state where the parent applied for the card ...
... and the last four numbers is one added, and the middle numbers follow a normal pattern.
So you can take your number, subtract one and that is a valid number ...
... from someone who was probably born in the same hospital as you ...
... at about the same time.
In other words, a fraudster who knows the time and location of your birth, ...
... can probably look up the first five numbers in a table.
Institutes ask for the last four numbers to identify you as you ...
... which means that it is not too difficult to put together your number ...
... after a security leak somewhere or after connecting a number of puzzle pieces.
The physical map also does not help:
Literally a piece of cardboard, depending on when it was issued, not even laminated.
The social security department wrote ...
... "Not to be used as identification" on the cards ...
... as a useless attempt to stop institutions from asking for the cards as IDs, ...
... because there is nothing on the card that can identify a person, ...
... but in the end they gave up and deleted these words, ...
... because, as opposed to passports or driving licenses, ...
... you can assume that all Americans have this one card.
All this means that your social security card and number ...
... probably have worse security than your library card, ...
... while it is many times more important.
It is unsuitable as a secure number, ...
it is unsuitable as a good identity card, ...
... but it is at least universal *, which is why people use it.
Oh hello, little star, my old friend.
No of course not. This program is actually not universal:
Not everyone has a social security number ...
... and not everyone contributes to the program.
If you do not want to pay, all you have to do is:
One: Never received social security benefits ...
... and give up all your rights to having it in the future.
What looks fair. You must also:
Being a member of a religion opposite to the idea of ​​social security.
Normally because it is a type of insurance and an insurance is a type of gambling.
That is harder, but you can also ...
... start your own religion, if you take tax avoidance very seriously.
But your own religion must then:
Taking care of his elderly and dependent members, ...
... which means that you have to copy a social security program or something similar for your religion.
(while you are also against the idea of ​​social security)
And if creating a contradictory religion doesn't scare you ...
Finally, it must have existed in one piece since 1950.
Which indicates that this exception was exclusively written ...
... for the Amish and Mennonites and destroys your plans, ...
... unless you want to undergo a substantial lifestyle change.
It doesn't stop there:
Keep searching and you will find several other very strange exceptions, ...
... including some railroad workers or firefighters or police or teachers (but only in Chicago).
Normally these are groups that long ago ...
... were given the opportunity to exit the program when it was created.
So nothing is obvious.
And that's how it is with this social security card:
Contains a national number for citizens who do not want one, ...
... on an identity card that is not suitable for identification, ...
... given to all citizens - except when it is not ...
... for a universal program, except when it is not.
This episode was made possible in part by Squarespace.
Whether you need a domain, website or online store, ...
... make your next move with Squarespace.
Does your brand new social security-avoiding religion ...
... need a website to spread the good news?
Then use Squarespace '"all-in-one" platform.
Their beautiful templates make it easy to set up and there is nothing to install, ...
... update or upgrade, ever.
Squarespace is what I use for my personal website and I really think you should use it too.
Start the free trial today at SquareSpace.com ...
... and use the "Gray" code to get a 10% discount on your first purchase.